si vous avez regardé les vidéos
précédentes vous savez maintenant quoi
faire si vous tombez sur des gens qui
ont des troubles de la conscience et de
la respiration
mais si vous croisez quelqu'un qui fait
une hémorragie vous faites quoi on va
voir ça tout de suite doug ross étudia
reyes grigoryan michaela quinn derek
shepherd elliot reid
tel est leur secret pour être si sexy so
débit ça vous fait une bonne raison d'
apprendre à sauver des vies
l'autre raison c'est qu apprendre à
sauver des vies ça peut sauver des vies
dimanche petit repas de famille posé et
soudain tonton rené décide de découper
le poulet
le problème c'est qu'avant de passer à
table il ya eu l'apéro et l'apéro tonton
rené il aime bien ça résultat tonton
rené fait un peu blessé bon sans aller
jusque là
tonton rené s'est salement entaillée et
ça saigne beaucoup ça saigne tellement
que ça s'arrête pas tout seul et qu'il
faut faire quelque chose pour éviter
qu'ils se vide de son sang parce qu'il
en a que 5 litres et qu'avec un litre de
moins à mettre déjà sa vie en main et si
le sang est très rouge et qui gicle par
saccades c'est que c'est une artère qui
est touché et ça peut aller très vite
je vous propose de voir ce qu'on peut
faire démonstration à l'appui avec notre
mannequin de secourisme
commencez par chalmé tonton rené
allonger le sur le sol et demandé que
quelqu'un prévienne les secours
demandez lui d'appuyer très fort sur sa
plaie même si ça fait mal
et s'il n'y arrive pas tout seul fait le
à sa place mais en respectant quelques
précautions
mettez des gants ou un sac en plastique
ou au pire un linge propre entre votre
peau et la plèbe tonton rené surélever
le monde qui saigne et maintenez la
compression en attendant l'arrivée des
secours
si vous avez besoin de lâcher un moment
vous pouvez tenter un pansement
compressif recouvrer complètement la
plaie avec un linge est entouré le tout
avec une bande ou un morceau de tissu
assez grand pour tout recouvrir et faire
deux fois le tour du monde
serrez bien fort et surveillé que
l'hémorragie est bien stoppé si c'est
pas le cas
reprenez la compression manuel haut et
quand on perd beaucoup de sang ça donne
soif est possible que tonton rené
réclament à boire ne lui donnait rien
même pas de l'eau sinon je peux pas
avoir un juste un petit bijou la juste
un doigt
si vous avez un doute rappeler le 15 ils
vous diront quoi faire en les attendant
à dernière chose dès que vous pouvez
lavez vous les mains le sang c'est pas
très propre voix la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo
abonnez vous pour pas rater ça et en
attendant prenez soin de vous prenez
soin des autres et portez vous bien